[Musique]
le jeu commence à creuser ce prêt dans
deux parties ici tu as commencé ici à
peu près
l'histoire commence par quelques balles
de fusil trouvaient au fond d'un jardin
picardie
en 2006 fabienne misère à 14 ans il est
passionné par l'histoire de la première
et de la seconde guerre mondiale
ce qu'il découvre derrière sa maison est
un cadeau du ciel
je consacre aux ailes à la sortie des
cartouches et les cartouches entière
pour moi j'ai retrouvé peut-être 30 ou
40 kg aux cartouches vraiment des seaux
entiers avant tout remonte à la surface
quelques jours plus tard il se retourne
et je continue à creuser creuser et
bassel après je tombais sans lui promet
objets arrivés premiers ossements il
soit pareil c'est une telle surprise et
un petit quelque chose en plus en fait
les premiers ossements ces décotes que
j'ai retrouvée et moi au début je
restais des racines et quand j'ai
commencé à enlever japonais des
vertèbres la jeunesse là il ya quelque
chose c'est comme ça que j'ai reçues les
excités corps apprend que tu m'as en
croisière formé à colonne vertébrale
puis les coques le bras et prêché
arriver jusqu'au crâne que j'ai retrouvé
tout ce qui était un signe de colle donc
son ultime bataille ni pegg et les
insignes des paul marty canada la
découverte de fabié va déclencher la
plus importante en cas d'identification
de soldats canadiens
or durant la première guerre mondiale
une enquête menée de front par des
scientifiques une anthropologue
médico-légal une généalogiste au début
l'offensive des historiens militaires
cent ans plus tard ces jeunes hommes
portés disparus sortent de l'ombre et
leurs familles viennent se recueillir là
où ils sont tombés au combat
[Musique]
la cathédrale d'amiens une présence
majestueuse au centre de la ville tout
autour des champs de blé de betteraves à
sucre des éoliennes et des cimetières
avec ces stèles blanches reposent des
dizaines de milliers de soldats
un paysage tranquille
mais il ya près de 100 ans le 8 to 1918
se livre ici une bataille excessivement
meurtrière la bataille damien la ville
est convoité pour son importance
stratégique son réseau de chemin de fer
qui mène entre autres vers paris amiens
ne doit pas passer aux allemands la taxe
surprise des alliés aux petites heures
du matin désorganise complètement
l'armée allemande
joe des airs de l'artillerie à la
cavalerie d'étendre aux tirs de mortier
les alliés sont partout
mais également des cribles
1918 comme étant pour eux le jour le
plus sombre de la guerre cette
compréhensive alliés et canadiennes et
pour moi beaucoup plus importante et
beaucoup plus significative que la
capture de la crête de vimy qui restait
une opération assez localiser sylvestre
bresson et guide historique alors que
ici on parle vraiment d'une percée
canadienne du front et du front allemand
qui va mener à la victoire finale
les soldats canadiens
redoutable ils ont prouvé à vimy
fashioned l épreuve on encore une fois
fait appel à eux pour combattre en
première ligne
canadiens qui n'ont eux sont victorieux
il ya une certaine effervescence marque
pilot est professeur d'histoire en
picardie ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que cette bataille d'amiens ce n'est pas
la fin c'est le début de la fin ici il
ya eu le premier coup de boutoir
suffisamment puissant pour faire douter
le haut commandement allemand et pour
surtout faire reculer rapidement pour la
première fois les troupes allemandes
les canadiens se battent sans relâche
pendant trois jours et atteignent le
petit village d'à lui en picardie dans
le nord de la france
là on joue 1918 il n'ya plus d'habitants
à lui ils ont été évacués quelques mois
plus tôt les champs ne sont pas cultivés
il y à de la boue et des tranchées
allemandes partout
des tranchées allemandes une troisième
ligne également points c'est un réseau
très dense de tranchées allemandes
protégés par des parts des réseaux de
barbelés qui apparaissent aussi sur les
cas pour silvestre dressant des
champs-de-bataille n'ont plus de secret
la mémoire du sol est encore très très
présente comme ces piquets de ces
piquets qui servait à maintenir les
réseaux de deux fils de fer barbelés
comme ici des shrapnels ces fameuses
billes de plomb dont dont on parlait des
balles j'envoie unis si ça avait l'air
assez l'habitude quand on connaît le
terrain c'est une cartouche allemande
douille donc à lui est là bas alors à
lui à lui là bas on distingue bien
l'église les y salue le clocher le
village à l'identique traversé comme ça
on est vraiment sur la l'endroit de la
progression des des canadiens 18 10
sieverts vers le village de lui
en fait ici c'était les tranchées
allemandes la voit sur la photo aérienne
de 1916 concots jude airlines juste
derrière les tranchées à le monde jusque
là sur le côté du village des villages
et allemands contre braga ce sont les
soldats du 78e bataillon des grenadiers
de winnipeg qui effectue cette avancée
spectaculaire en territoire allemand et
repousse l'ennemi malgré la fatigue et
l'épuisement
cette carte retrouvé dans les archives
illustrent bien cette percée pour le 78e
bataillon à lui c'est le moment où ils
sont en-avant de toute l'armée
canadienne et même de toutes les armées
alliées qui attaquent donc c'est quelque
chose d'important
mais en allant aussi loin en terre
ennemie ils se retrouvent du même coup
isolé
ils sont allés très vite les autres
batailles en d'ampus monde
devant te vont surgir les soldats
d'élite de l'armée allemande
le très menaçants chorale paix appelés à
la rescousse
les allemands n'ont pas digéré
l'offensive surprise du 8 août ils
veulent sortir ces canadiens d'alu
la contre attaque est féroce et 78e doit
tenir dans cet enfer on voit dans les
documents d'archivés du bataillon que ce
sont les ordres n'ont pas le choix nous
devons garder allumée cot cot ses
soldats ont manifesté chacun une
bravoure extraordinaire pour tenir alors
qu'il aurait été plus simple de se
replier une bière c'est une série
d'erreurs de commandement pour les
soldats qui étaient là cette bataille
était devenue incompréhensible comme le
démontrent ses messages du franc à lui
est devenu un bourbier soldats sont
encerclés
l'ennemi bombarde à lui il n'y a plus de
communication entre les flancs et 78e
recul des avions ennemis nous l'at la
fumée blanche pour signaler la position
d'eca native l'ennemi avance toujours
envoyer des renforts
c'est la confusion et finalement des
chèques à lui est maintenant dans les
mêmes des nuits je n'ai plus aucun de
crue le lendemain un nouvel ordre est
donné
les brancardiers doivent évacuer les
blessés c'est urgent
au terme de ces combats qui ont fait une
centaine de victimes
trente cinq soldats du 78e bataillon
sont portées disparues jusqu'au jour où
un adolescent curieux retrouve huit
d'entre eux le premier corps en coin te
retrouver le premier était sur le côté
comme ça
la tête vers la bas le deuxième était
sur le dos la tête par ici donc cela
qu'après je fais des marches la
commission des sépultures de guerre du
commonwealth situé à une heure à lui est
venue récupérer les ossements des deux
soldats en nettoyant le site
elle retrouve le squelette de notre
soldat qui quittent les lieux
favier lui continue il passe ses jours
de congés à fouiller le sol avec le plus
grand soin comme un archéologue ses
parents ne le voit plus de la journée le
soir où j'allais voir on voyait plus de
terre plus la médecin quand ils avaient
creusé même une galerie rentrer la tête
en abandonnant pour sortir un nouveau
jeu puis presque raté les eaux est donc
en moins on allait voir de temps en
temps parce qu'eux mêmes soient amateurs
l'étranger de l'appeler pour manger quoi
parce qu'il n'est pas manger c'était une
passion que j'étais à fond dedans il
voyait plus que ce à quoi les façons il
ne parlait que d'eux sans sa ténacité et
sa patience sont récompensés fabien
trouve cinq autres ce qu'elle est c'est
vraiment bien de façon qu'ils le travail
c'était vraiment avec indemnités pour
youtube brown le travail qu'accomplit
fabien est exceptionnel sa rigueur et
son nom était aussi malheureusement ici
on est pas mal de gens qui peut
peut-être je vais encore et il va nous
donner le ce qu'elle est tous les
ossements après mais eux ils veulent
garder tous les anciens qui va avec et à
quelques fois malheureusement si mal
des fois on arrive je passe et toutes
les choses qui peuvent identifier le
père sont elles sont parties ces objets
sont bien souvent vendus dans des
brocantes sur internet sans égard aux
familles c'est quand même décevant
vous voyez le corps vous dites ça fera
cuire un petit truc au coeur c'est
émouvant
après vous pensez derrière toute la
famille à l'histoire
et puisque les gens derrière ils vont
rechercher ce qu'on va faire quelque
chose cette jeune femme les choses en
fait clegg est anthropologue médico
légal au ministère de la défense
nationale
elle se rappelle sa première visite dans
le jardin de fabien j'ai sauté dans tout
pour voir s'il n'y avait pas autre chose
ça a été formidable mais non il n'y
avait rien d'autre fabien a très bien
travaillé
il a tout retrouvé tout seul dans mon
jardin les deux vitrines plus le sac
l'os et des restes de tissus devait
d'uniformes favier a transformé le
grenier de la maison en musée waterman
canada février 1909
après l'avant tout ce qui était des
peignes moustache cheveux qui reste
d'une pipe
le 6 mars est inhabituel pour nous de
trouver huit personnes c'est
extraordinaire imaginé il ya vingt-huit
mille canadiens disparus et on en a
retrouvé huit dans le jardin public
on en retrouve dans la région mais c'est
la retrouve un soldat allemand on a
retrouvé un soldat français marc
thoumelin soldats anglais mais ça que
huit corps bien sûr les autres c'est
assez rare mais moins tendues soit dans
la région de martrou votants deux corps
qui sont ces huit heures soit à césar
ceci appartient aux soldats williams en
son nom son numéro de matricule ces
religions respectives
la commission des sépultures de guerre
du commonwealth est responsable de la
fabrication et de l'entretien des tombes
des soldats morts durant les deux
grandes guerres
ce sont 2500 cimetière dans plus de 170
pays
ici dans nord de la france que se trouve
la morgue
flore clegg va maintenant prendre le
relais de fabien huit de ces voix qui
contiennent les ossements des soldats
retrouvés à alieu chacune porte une
inscription halluin à lui 2 et ainsi de
suite
[Musique]
durant cette bataille 35 soldats sont
morts au combat et n'ont jamais été
retrouvés
alors elle consulte sept listes de
disparus 9h05
nous vérifions la taille et l'âge des
disparus nous connaissons certains
détails sur les circonstances de leur
mort nous les comparons avec les
grandeurs et les âges de nos soldats
par exemple pour halluin nous avons cinq
ou six disparus qui se ressemblent qui
ont entre 5 pi 6 ess à pied 8 qui sont
dans la vingtaine avancé alors déjà on a
réussi à réduire les possibilités encore
une fois lors on peut remercier fabien
pour son travail rigoureux
il a fait très attention s'il y avait un
a thing bouton auprès d'un corps il
s'est assuré que tous restent ensemble
il a aussi pris des photos et la
facilité mon travail deux objets ont
particulièrement retenu son attention
on a trouvé un petit coeur c'était avec
le troisième corps à l'intérieur il y a
des cheveux se croit elle il y a aussi
un petit morceau de carton sur lequel
est écrit quelque chose on ne voit pas
très bien
j'aurais aimé qu'il soit inscrit qu'une
telle personne n'a donné à une autre
mais ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça ce
n'est pas aussi simple
c'était probablement un bracelet c'est
comme ça qu on les vendait cette plaque
d'identification est en métal la
majorité était fait en carton et se sont
détériorées avec le temps sur celles-ci
sont inscrits un nom initial sims w
au début nous étions très excités parce
que nous avions cette claque
d'identification au nom du things
elles étaient près de à lui 4 mai les
corps ont été jetés pêle-mêle dans la
fosse ils étaient les hommes sur les
autres on a découvert que si ns était en
réalité à lui 5 et non pas à lui quatre
là où on a trouvé la plaque
d'identification
[Musique]
une fois le travail à la morgue complété
c'est ici dans le nord de l'ontario
attendu b que l'anc est l'identification
de ces soldats se transporte fait
parvenir au docteur à marginal et à son
équipe des dents et les os de la
mâchoire soldats retrouver ses soldats
ont donné leur vie pour la liberté et la
paix non nous faisons partie du
processus d'identification
nous en sommes très fiers l'équipe du
docteur chan va extraire l'adn
mitochondrial qui résiste le plus au
passage du temps et se dégradent moins
que l'adn nucléaire que l'on utilise
habituellement pour identifier quelqu'un
l'adn mitochondrial est transmis
uniquement par la mer et seuls ses
filles leur transmettront à leurs
enfants une fois cet adn obtenu il
faudra donc chercher dans la lignée
maternelle de chaque soldat pour trouver
un donneur potentiel sol
c'est tout un défi de trouver ces
registre à l'autre bout de la ville
la généalogiste janet way se met au
travail
la tâche est colossale comme on l'a vu
un squelette retrouvé peut correspondre
à cinq soldats inscrit sur la liste des
disparus
temps l'âge et la grandeur sont
semblables moi j'aime mon travail de
généalogistes est d'étudier le dossier
de chaque soldat disparu je pense de
sortie us de faire son arbre
généalogique ou d'en trouver un qui
existe déjà et de chercher des donneurs
spécifiques
[Musique]
jeannette fois et va fouiller les
registres de différents pays
à l'époque beaucoup de jeunes hommes
quittent l'europe pour trouver du
travail au canada canada etats unis
angleterre ecosse espagne et suède
nous sommes vraiment une société
multiculturelle la généalogiste consulte
autant les vieux documents des
presbytères que facebook et malgré la
complexité de cette recherche
elle parvient à retrouver des neveux et
nièces des petits neveux et petites
nièces et même l'arrière petite-fille de
la tente d'un soldat
pour prélever leur adn il faut bien sûr
obtenir leur consentement
il ya quelques années si vous receviez
un appel de la défense nationale qui
vous demandait de donner un échantillon
d'haleine clic les gens vous raccrochez
la limo n'étant que c'était bizarre
maintenant les gens sont plus au courant
les premiers résultats arrivent en 2013
sept ans après la découverte de fabien
sur les huit soldats quatre sont
identifiés 4 qui ont maintenant un
visage une histoire et surtout un nom le
soldat sims quand on a retrouvé la
plaque
si william sims 24 ans un jeune fermier
de ressaut au manitoba
la cloud making 29 ans un boucher
d'origine écossaise résidents de
winnipeg le seul du groupe qui était
marié il a épousé sa fiancée durant la
guerre lors d'une permission
john ostrander suédois d'origine 34 ans
contremaître de chemin de fer au
manitoba sergent dans le 78e et clifford
brown hills un agent d'immeuble de
winnipeg
âgé de 26 ans devenu lieutenant dans le
78e bataillon les grenadiers de winnipeg
pour moi c'est très excitant
ça veut dire que j'ai bien fait mon
travail tant de choses peuvent mal aller
nous avions besoin de la science de
l'adn des isotopes tout l'aspect
historique
nous étions toute une équipe et nous
avons réussi c'est génial
[Musique]
c'était m'ouvre puisque nous remontons
dans le temps cent ans en arrière
tout ce qui s'est passé durant la
première guerre tout ce que ses soldats
ont dû vivre cette nouvelle fabien
l'attend depuis longtemps mais ce qu'il
souhaite encore plus ces rencontres et
les descendants de ces soldats sur le
ferry qui se déplace à cette année sur
terre - travail commençait et sera très
bien fini important je pense qu'elle va
être motion et ça va lui faire il va
voir ça aboutit à quelque chose avant la
vie votre combat façon à mon avis il
attend que ça lui
[Musique]
à la fois bien voici la famille makine
c'est fabien fabien selanne est le neveu
de williams et biz c'est à bien il
arrive des états unis du canada de
l'angleterre
le droit qui à 91 ans aimé ce type c'est
l'oncle de
c'est le neveu et sa femme ils sont
venus pour mieux connaître une partie de
leur histoire pour rencontrer fabien et
pour voir l'endroit où le rail elle est
tombée sous les balles allemandes
seule la famille de jon leyne d'or ce
contremaître de chemin de fer n'a pu
faire le voyage mais ce peu dangereux
mais après ce que l'on retrouve quand
même pas mal ou qui sait pas qu'on
s'habitue mais presque
pour marc pilot passionné d'histoire
c'est un moment de grande émotion
les assaillants et soyeux méricourt noël
et pour fabien c'est l'aboutissement
d'un rêve d'une longue attente
le moment est enfin arrivé de leur faire
découvrir son jardin
dès qu'on avait retrouvé les corps et
seule chose que je voulais ouest jamais
eu d'acte la famille qui pour se
recueillir ce qui est là aujourd'hui
habitants a pris au général en comptant
les bus j'ai des frissons mais quand il
a vu les boutons pour la première fois
est ce qu'il réalisait que c'était des
soldats canadiens parce que j'ai vu la
feuille d'érable est en dessous ces
barricades
les questions sont nombreuses ont été
les corses à bienne alors le le premier
était juste ici la tête comme ça sur sur
le côté sur le côté droit
le deuxième était donc plus qu'ils y
soient sur le dos la tête là bas après
les cinq autres partis est vraiment les
uns sur les autres
est ce qu'il y avait des armes près de
kiev revenir j'ai retrouvé des munitions
cartes s'ils n'ont pas pas dans ce qu'il
y avait des amis fort je te retrouver
des boutons chacun leur apporter un peu
de terre de cet ancien champ de bataille
en énorme sur tig
fabien fait une autre découverte
[Musique]
d'autres encore
c'est avec plaisir que nous vous
remercions pour cette magnifique
opportunité que vous nous avez donné de
nous unir comme une seule et même
famille
cliff ronning 91 ans et sa femme
marguerite 89 ans ont tenu à être du
voyage
c'est un premier séjour en europe pour
ce couple de caroline du nord
nous avons demandé à notre médecin il
nous a dit réalisé clé fertig est le
fils de beci la soeur du lieutenant
clifford et brown hills
il a été nommé en l'honneur de son oncle
disparu
c'est lui qui a passé le test d'adr
d'une habituellement quand tu vas chez
son médecin avec un kit adn c'est pour
faire un test de paternité
ils devaient se dire qu'est ce qui peut
bien se passer avec messieurs tig
on lui a expliqué l'oncle de monsieur
tig à diriger ses troupes durant des
affrontements d'alu il est mort en
donnant l'assaut il était le premier à
sortir de la tranchée pour voir s'ils
les chantent était libre il a été tués
probablement par une mitrailleuse
c'était très rapide et en regardant le
crâne j'ai vu qu'il avait été à ça la
tête
il est probablement mort très rapidement
la plupart des soldats d'al uppr sont
morts avec de graves blessures à la tête
[Musique]
en examinant les ossements et les dents
des soldats lors clegg a vu toute la
souffrance que pouvait endurer ces
hommes au plan des quatrième avec ceux
qui m'affecte le plus c'est quand je
regarde l'état de leurs dents en plus de
tout ce qu'ils vivaient ils avaient des
cars et des abcès c'était très fréquent
ces hommes étaient mal en point
parce qu'ils souffraient constamment il
ne se plaignait pas il continuait malgré
tout quel contraste avec aujourd'hui il
était plus rude que ceux de la seconde
guerre est certainement plus que ceux de
notre génération
physiquement mais probablement aussi
mentalement c'est tous des morceaux de
manger au super fragile
c'est tout ce qui reste des deux
uniformes en fait donc ses boutons
canadien fabien tient remettre à chaque
famille un objet qu'il a trouvé garza
le stylo plume ne peut appartenir qu'à
une officier fabien l'offre at lifting
donc quand je retrouvais le le deuxième
corps celui de sony landes
il y avait ce stylo là à côté donc mc
cullough pen est en parfaite état et
aujourd'hui ils ont profité pour pour
leurs maîtres pour vous en souvenir
voilà
l'adami et plaisir
c'est une surprise
c'est une surprise de l'avoir trouvé
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
extraordinaire on reproche quelquefois à
la science son caractère froid mais elle
permet aussi de très belles histoires
le petit choeur retrouvé près des
ossements demeure toujours une énigme et
cette plaque d'identification reviendra
peut-être au neveu de williams inc
mais on devra d'abord consulter les
documents de la succession
le soldat si vous avant de partir à la
guerre avait tout légué à sa mère au cas
où il lui arriverait quelque chose
c'était la tante de notre soldat parmi
le groupe
une famille a fait le voyage même si les
résultats des dn ne sont pas encore
conclu ban celle de albert achmed
infirmiers ontarien de 27 ans albert
achmed est devenu orphelin à cinq ans il
a d'abord perdu sa mère d'une fièvre et
l'année suivante son père qui était
d'origine marocaine
il dirigeait une troupe d'acrobates en
angleterre à 9 ans le jeune albert fait
partie des milliers d'orphelins envoyé
au canada
mais il était encore bébé c'est quand il
a quitté pour le canada ils ont pris
cette photo deux ans plus tard je ne
pensais jamais voir ça en 1916
albert armes est décès de s'enrôler et
repart pour l'angleterre il est appelé
au front seulement le 8 août 1918 durant
la bataille damier il meurt le 11 ou à à
lui sa guerre n'a duré que trois jours
[Musique]
[Rires]
avant cette rencontre devant la
cathédrale d'amiens
les deux femmes ne s'étaient jamais vus
et anglaise
veronica est américaine c'est l'adn
mitochondrial qui les réunit leurs deux
arrières grands mères sont des soeurs et
les tentes du soldat à remède
ce dernier fait partie de la trentaine
de soldats portés disparus a à lui mais
ce n'est pas encore certain qu'il soit
parmi les huit
même si nous ne sommes pas sûrs à 100%
je suis certaine qu'il fait partie des
huit ans ma mère droite
[Musique]
l'endroit le plus important ces familles
c'est à lui un petit morceau jardin de
quelques mètres carrés
parce que c'est là qu'il y à leurs
ancêtres et ça ça ça vaut quelque chose
c'est forcément très très haut
c'est l'endroit le plus important ces
familles avant la tour eiffel avant le
louvre avant les beautés touristique de
la france
peut-être considéré comme ça c'est pour
moi c'est pas grand chose quand j'ai
juste trouvé un accord ne savoir que
notre côté de l'atlantique c'est perçu
autrement vraiment se fait vraiment
plaisir nous personnellement c'était la
guerre c'était les anglais les
américains et puis la france
et puis c'est tout donc pensez posent au
pays d'en faire profiter car en faisant
des recherches qu'on a su que les
canadiens devaient libérer à lui c'est
vrai qu'on le savait port partant pour
les libérateurs daly était au courant
redire mais voilà
les libérateurs d'alu n'auront pu tenir
que quelques heures avant l'assaut final
des allemands
[Musique]
à la commission des sépultures de guerre
du commonwealth
le travail est commencé les noms des
soldats retrouvés seront enfin gravé sur
la pierre c'est mon oncle le frère de ma
mère
elle parlait de lui elle a perdu deux
frères durant la première guerre
mondiale
votre mère a dû avoir beaucoup de ben
oui
la famille simon envoyé quatre garçons à
la guerre de ne sont jamais revenus
alexander et william
avant de mourir dans le jardin de fabien
williams a fait toutes les grandes
batailles des canadiennes vimy la côte
soixante dix à shenzhen
aves son ami je trouve ça vraiment bien
qu'ils puissent avoir une sépulture et
qu'il soit reconnu ma mère aurait été
tellement heureuse et fière
[Musique]
c'est très intéressant de voir une
chasse quand je pense qu'il y a quelques
mois je ne savais rien de cette histoire
[Musique]
pour les employés de la commission c'est
une grande première le nom de famille
c'est important pour nous
on aimerait savoir quelle bataille on
sait ça veut dire qu'il ya au moins 2
quel régiment toubous et le primaire et
thomas haas émouvante
[Musique]
peut associer en fait une
un des vins
une des premières fois qu'on voit ça
[Musique]
une autre première pour ces familles
l'impressionnant mémorial de vimy où se
trouvent inscrits les noms de plus de
onze mille soldats canadiens disparus
durant la première guerre mondiale
parmi eux ceux des soldats lui c'est
incroyable ces deux monuments tellement
imposant son nom est là et il veut
partie de notre famille
c'est vraiment extraordinaire on aurait
pu venir ici avant sans savoir que nous
faisons partie de tout ça c'est une
histoire extraordinaire
ça y est on y est
notre ennemi qui naît le grand oncle de
maureen mais keane une s e jeune boucher
qui s'est mariée durant une permission
de quelques jours il est mort au combat
deux ans plus tard sans jamais avoir
revu sa christina jusqu'à tout récemment
sa petite nièce ne connaissais même pas
son existence
je ne me rappelle pas avoir entendu
parler de lui je n'ai connu que ma grand
mère je savais que la bonne soeur on
l'avait rencontrée mais c'est tout
personne ne parlait de lui je trouve ça
triste
il ya eu de chance si vous aviez la
chance de rencontrer votre ombre
qu'est ce que vous lui diriez que nous
sommes vraiment fiers de glee que je
suis vraiment content de le rencontrer
de nuit serrer la main et l'embrassé
l'un des murs à rome
[Musique]
et
c'est un nul c'est pour lieutenant clé
free nuland
c'est mon oncle et j'ai été nommé en son
âme heures c'est vraiment excitant
toutes ces informations qu'on a trouvé
et de voir qu'il soit enfin connue
toutes ces années ils ont donné leur vie
pour la liberté
c'était émouvant oui
pas dû fuir comment vous sentez-vous
devant tous ces noms c'est un énorme
travail il ya plus de 11000 nos sur le
monument on avait tant que je n'aurai
pas trouvé qui ils sont donc je n'aurais
pas trouvé une histoire rattaché à
chacun de ces noms jolie du travail à
faire
les restes humains des soldats morts ne
seront pas rapatrié au canada mais
enterrés avec leurs frères d'armes dans
ce cimetière à quai tout près d'alu la
cérémonie militaire est prévue pour 2015
c'est ici que nous allons entrer vos
proches
cette grande nouvelle l'horaire l'a
gardé pour la fin ni site
le soldat numéro 3 ici le sergent linder
le soldat s'est mise
[Musique]
sept allemands un bel endroit ici dans
un sens c'est réconfortant pour moi on
leur permet surtout d'entrer dans la
mort il ya une différence entre être
disparu et puis être tombé au champ
d'honneur morts au combat avec une
sépulture bien identifiés au milieu de
ses frères dans le cimetière au
reposeront ses soldats est situé à
quelques mètres d'un autre lieu de
sépulture
celui où sont enterrés leurs anciens
ennemis les croix noire allemande
rappelle les mêmes batailles sur les
huit soldats retrouvés à lui il en reste
dont quatre à identifier il ya aussi ce
petit coeur et ses deux mèches de
cheveux
ce petit coeur a finalement livré son
secret en le nettoyant délicatement un
nom est apparu celui de e wisely dans
les états de service d'un des
combattants d'alu est inscrit ceux ci
advenant ma mort je lègue 10 livres à
mademoiselle woods lee
ce soldat c'est sydney à l'idée un jeune
fermier de 22 ans joueur de tambour au
sein du 78e le cinquième soldat d'al
yeux elisabeth et sydney était fiancé
elle lui a donné ce choeur avant son
départ pour la guerre mais ce n'est pas
ce pendentif qui a servi à identifier à
l'idée même s'il y a contribué ce sont
les tests d'isotopes qui sont faits
lorsque l'adn mitochondrial ne donne pas
de résultat asio en grandissant votre
corps absorbe les isotopes qu'on
retrouve dans l'eau potable
il se fixe à l'émail de vaud dans une
fois dans l'émail des dents ça reste
toujours en analysant les dents nous
pouvons dire quel soldat a vécu dans tel
parti d'angleterre et qui ont su
déménagé en alberta à la fin de la
vingtaine c'est très utile
les tests 10 octobre c'est le dernier
recours car la science a ses limites
pour l'instant en attendant d'autres
résultats
les cas se multiplient
ainsi a été découvert à lens dans nord
de la france en construisant une
nouvelle prison et en agrandissant
l'hôpital pour enfants situé juste en
face les travailleurs ont découvert des
ossements en ou 1917 soit un an avant à
lui un lieu ici la bataille de la côte
66 pour se sont illustrés les
canadiennes c'est pas juste un soldat ou
de soda c'est c'est vraiment 15-20 soda
c'est et il n'y a pas juste des
canadiens a cédé mélange de beaucoup d
des français et allemands mais grand
maître année canadiens australiens
c'est plus complexe leur club travaille
actuellement sur cinq nouveaux cas
relier cette récente découverte de
prendre dans la prison dans les prisons
autres
en plus les ossements retrouvés à lens
la terre a révélé une quantité énorme de
munitions il ya eu donc plus de 600 au
but 2-2 découverte d'un obus et pièces
d'artillerie
également des dessins dont des tunnels
dans laquelle étaient stockés tous et
toutes ses munitions d'un point de vue
pratique nous ça nous occasionne aussi
beaucoup de retard donc ici arnott
chantier nous ont plus ou moins
pénalisés mais sinon oui
passé ce détail lasser
et on retravaille ils sont en quelque
sorte on essaie on effacer les traces
[Musique]
fabien est aujourd'hui gendarmes et
militaires ils éprouvent énormément de
respect pour ces hommes qui sont tombés
au fond de son jardin
il porte fièrement leur uniforme lorsque
sont organisés des reconstitutions
historiques expliquant aux gens ce que
j'ai retrouvé expliqué la tenue pour moi
ça fait un peu honneur à ce genre mais
ce qui est absolument remarquable chez
fabien sait que l'histoire lui est entré
dans la peau dans le coeur dans l'esprit
est que depuis cette époque là il n'est
plus le même
il est quelque part un membre du 78e
oh
pour les familles fabien est un héros
celui qui a permis que ces jeunes sommes
venus au secours de la france sorte de
l'oubli
pour moi c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
normal je vais retrouver des corps où
j'étais passionné par sa veste pour moi
c'est normal
toute personne qui retrouve des corps
devrait faire les démarches pour au
moins ces gens là puissent est enterré
on va s'unir pour le rendent hommage
[Musique]
ces familles ont eu beaucoup de chance
quelque part en france un garçon de 14
ans plutôt que d'aller jouer avec ses
amis a préféré passer ses journées de
vacances seuls accusés se pointer fabien
a contribué à leur faire connaître leur
histoire et du même coup la nôtre
[Musique]
oh